hello everyone and welcome to another
game from the superbed rapid and Blitz
Tournament being played in Poland 2023
that it is Wesley so vs Richard and this
is their game from round three now uh
one of these gentlemen is one of the
leaders after day one but we are going
to discuss this after the game and also
thank you everyone uh who mentioned in
the comments of the previous video uh
that I forgot to updated the letter on
the little robot below me uh sometimes
it happens but it's good to know that
you know people pay attention to that
kind of stuff so that being said uh
let's check out the game I went through
all of the games that happened and I
thought you guys would enjoy this one
the most it's a real slack Fest so yeah
let's dive um let's dive straight into
it uh there we go uh sorry about that
let me just fix the board okay uh so
Wesley uh has the white pieces and he
opens with Ponte D4 we have Knight to F6
C4 E6 Knights to F3 and pawn to C5 so a
bit of a different move order but we
will end up in a balloon only very
quickly the 5d6 we have Knight to C3 e
characters on D5 and we have transposed
into the benoni defense C captures on D5
G6 and now Bishop to F4 now this is a
move that often troubled me when I first
started playing chess is that benoni was
one of the openings that I started
employing the S black against Pawn to D4
because I've started you know watching
some Michael tal games where he played
the benoni and of course he played it
very well so I thought maybe I could
play uh you know uh fun just like that
but after Bishop to F4 it always seemed
like okay now if I play Bishop to G7
will want this D6 Pawn just be a
weakness forever but the you know the
fact of the matter is no it won't so
just Bishop to G7 and now Pawn to E3 uh
Knight the B5 doesn't do anything
because just Queen to A5 check and of
course
um that's pretty pointless you have to
go back and then your entire position
just falls apart and even if you even if
E3 was played the Knight on B5 was
defended doesn't really make that much
of a difference so E3 we have castles
and now you might think uh well can't we
do it just now what what is Knight B5 we
just go after the palm and how can black
defend it I mean is black gonna play a
weird move like Knights the knights the
E8 no black will actually play something
like Ponte A6 and that's it uh capturing
the pawn is really bad for white if
Knight captures on D6 you will play
Knight to H5 go after the bishop who is
defending the Knight here and after
Knight captures and C8 Knight captures
an F4 he captures an F4 Bishop captures
on B2 Black's position is just better
let's see Rook B1 Bishop C3 check okay
you will castle at some point with the
bishop to E2 and castles but let's say
Knight to D7 you will recap or you will
capture and see it with the rook and
after Bishop to E2 Rook captures on C8
uh let's say castles and now Knight to
F6 you will also lose the D5 pawn and
only black can be better here so that's
why it just spawned the H3 if some of
you were wondering and now uh here's a
that isn't played all that often usually
black just goes Knight A6 to C7 and it
does make sense because uh one thing
that the bishop on F4 does is prevents
Knight the D7 to E5 in in some
variations of course this Knight has to
move for you to go to E5 with this
Knight but if you play Knight D7 then
Bishop captures on D6 that's one of the
problems and uh uh this I mean this can
be solved in many different ways but uh
uh Richie decides to go for Knight to E8
and now the pawn is defended and now you
can play Knight to D7 to E5 so let's see
what happens here Bishop D2 uh Knights
to D7 we have castles and just Knights
the E5
uh we have knighted the D2 also one of
the uh ideas when playing against the
benoni is just put the Knight on C4 the
Knight will be extremely strong they are
going after the D6 pawn and it's uh well
sort of one of the objectives that that
you should achieve uh we have Pawn to F5
and now there is a game where the G3 was
played also Knight the C4 is a non move
but Wesley goes to Bishop back to H2
first and it is now as of move 13 that
we have a completely new game uh so we
have Knights to C7 uh and pawn to A4 now
controlling the B5 Square you don't want
to see Pawn to B5 on the board we have
Queen to E7 and now Rook to E1 with
Queen to B3 uh sorry uh Bishop to D7
Queen to B3 and now Knights the A6
rapper now offers the B7 pawn and as
this is a rapid game he maybe uh feels
that uh Wesley will not be able to
capture it because what if your your
queen gets trapped but that's exactly
what Wesley plays Queen capture some B7
and he says show me show me the danger
behind capturing this pawn and okay an
apple plays Knights the B4 now he is
threatening Rook after B8 but Wesley
plays Bishop captures on E5 and now the
problem is if you go for Rook F to B8
there's a very tricky line here uh
Bishop captures on D6 and now after
Queen captures Knights the C4 and now if
you move the queen then Queen can just
go to C7 so you can just trade let's say
real captors Knight captures now attacks
the rook and if Rook to B6 attacking the
Knight you will just play Knight back to
C4 attack The Rook now let's ignite the
seat you forking both of the Rooks but
now just Rook e to D1 and after Knight
captures you will capture on B6 a
captures Rook captures and the white
will be
uh much much better here you are up to
pawns and of course uh well it's it's
hard to say if you are winning by force
but you you should be much better here
so instead after Bishop captures an E5 a
rapper just recaptures Bishop captures
and E5 and now Bishop to B5 you remove
the defender of the bishop on D7 so now
uh you want to go after it we have a
rook F the d8 defending and now Rook e
to D1 uh sidestepping the fork uh Rook 8
to B8 and now Queen to C7 we have Rook B
to C8 attacking the queen queen B7 Rook
be at Queen D7 and Rogue B to C8 and now
Rapport is saying oh all right are you
maybe interested in a draw a good sir
Wesley but no Queen back to A5 Wesley
wants to continue fighting we have Ponte
A6 attacking the bishop and now we trade
captures captures and Knight the C4
putting pressure on that D6 Pawn we have
Rook to B8 now stopping Knights the B6
uh and Knight to A2 offering a trade and
while you could just trade here Richard
goes for Rook to A7 he defends the pawn
so now if the Knight is captured you
don't have to worry about Queen captures
than A6 uh we have Knight captures on B4
Rook capture some B4 and not just Knight
captures on E5 trading everything off
Queen captures on E5 and queen to d8
with check with King to G7 and The Rook
to D2
now uh defending the pawn on B2 and okay
the opponent B2 is attacked twice but if
you capture on B2 then Rook captures
Queen captures attacks the queen and the
ones The Rook moves uh you you could
play this but it uh maybe trades down a
bit too much so instead Rook 8 the B7
was played Just doubling up on the B
file and now Queen to A8 going after the
A6 Pawn Rook captures some B2 with Rook
captures Queen captures uh sorry Queen
captures attacking The Rook on A1 and
now just to Rogue back to F1 and now uh
not the defending on A6 with Queen to B6
uh uh rapper says I'm gonna start
pushing my Pawn right away you can have
the A6 spawn so he sacrifices it he
plays Pawn to C4 uh Queen captures an A6
Pawn to C3 with King to H2 getting the
King off of the back rank usually it
makes sense when someone is uh trying to
promote a pawn to a queen Pawn to C2 and
now Queen to C4 of course you have to
guard the queening square and now rapper
just plays Rook the B for he's trying to
kick the White Queen away from the
defense of the C1 Square Queen to C7
with checking the H6 and now a beautiful
move Queen captures on D6 sort of uh
offering
um uh uh Richard to go for uh I want to
see one but if you do this then The Rook
captures on C1 Queen captures and queen
captures on B4 and white is just winning
so instead we have rooked the C4 now
preparing Pawn to C1 but Wesley just
plays Queen to f8 check King to H5 and
queen to E7 and now you have to repeat
King to H6 and uh we and we end the game
with a repetition for example King H5
Queen to A7 and here we we would have a
nice repetition uh the problem is in the
game uh upon the H6 was played and this
is bad and another thing let's say you
play Pawn to C1 uh and just to bring a
Queen into the game look at this Rook
captures Queen captures uh on C1 and now
Queen captures an H7 with the check King
to G5 and now on the D6 and white just
wins on the spot the problem is uh you'd
think that white is trying to promote
the pawn here because the Rook cannot
get access to the D4 square but even if
you play Rook to see it and you stop the
pawn there's the beautiful F4 check and
now after King to F6 you see the real
reason behind Pawn to D6 that of course
is Queen to E7 Checkmate so that's uh
the problem so that's why the only move
to play here is spawn to H6 but a rapid
plays an even worse move and he plays
Ponte H6 now
instead of King to H6 and now Wesley has
a forced Checkmate and it's really a
beautiful one it's a force made in seven
moves not an easy one to spot just a
heads up Wesley did not find it during
the game because they were both
incredibly low on time but you guys I
imagine are very comfortable in your own
homes enjoying some chess so feel free
to pause the video and try to find this
beautiful forced mate in seven while I
give you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on finding this uh
elusive idea and for those of you who
just want to enjoy the show it is Pawn
to G4 with check it looks odd you know
starting uh how will Wesley miss this
it's literally a check move uh the
problem is after F captures on G4 you
don't recapture you play King G3 and now
there's the threat of Queen to H4
Checkmate and the black pawn is
preventing The Rook from guarding the H4
Square so what happens now Queen to B8
with check now you play Pawn to D6
absolutely incredible and after G
captures on H3 so The Rook finally uh
regains access to the H4 Square you play
Ponte F4 again with the threat of Queen
Tage for checkmate and now it's
Unstoppable uh the only way to stop it
is G5 but then Queen to F7 is just
Checkmate so absolutely incredible stuff
uh Wesley had no time to find it but I
hope you guys did a good job so instead
he played Pawn to D6 he started
advancing his pass Pawn but this allows
the rapper the chance to bounce back so
Queen so Pawn to C1 becomes a queen Rook
captures and C1 Rook captures and now
Pawn to G4 with check we have captors
captures with check King captures and
queen to E4 with check and now Wesley is
down a full Rook but that pawn is very
very close to promotion King to G5 Queen
to F or with check King to H5 and now
Pawn to D7 uh actually the way to win
this is Queen to F3 check and I'm just
gonna show it because it's beautiful
queen to F3 check King to G5 and now
King to H3 that's the way to do it
threatening uh Queen F4 check Queen to
H4 Checkmate and now after complete the
queen to E5 stopping this you just play
D7 and there's no
um avoiding it now if Queen T6 Check Yes
you connect with the pawn but just King
G3 you're again threatening Checkmate
there's uh no good way to stop this and
if you try repeating Queen D5 with check
there's even the incredible Queen to F4
with check and now after Queen captures
Pawn captures with check so you will
promote that pawn you you are within
Tempo King to F6 and now d8 Queen and of
course white completely winning but
incredible stuff they were they were
they were playing on increment they were
you know a few second only seconds on
the clock so D7 of by Wesley uh Queen to
D2 and now Queen to F3 with check King
G5 Queen to F4 checking the H5 Queen to
E5 with check Pawn to G5 and now Queen
to E8 with check Western now uh has his
d8 Square protected King to H4 and now
Queen to E4 with check the real move is
Queen to f8 as we've shown in the
thumbnail uh because from there you
guard the queening square you guard the
F2 Pawn so you don't have to worry about
Queen captures on F2 and you're also
threatening Queen captures on H4 with
check followed by Queen to H3 Checkmate
so I mean
uh Queen T4 check was played uh Wesley
repeats once a queen stage five Queen to
E8 with check King to H4 and now Wesley
spots it Queen to f8 absolutely a
beautiful uh there's just no defense
against this so Rook to H1 was played
the problem is if you capture the pawn
of course just Queen captures on H6
checking G4 and queen to H3 uh this uh
wonderful Checkmate uh so uh after a
queen Rook the eight one check uh of
course um arihadna has to give back the
rook in order to avoid Checkmate Queen
captures on D7 getting rid of the pawn
but now Queen captures an H6 with
checking to G4 and queen to A6 uh
defending the pawn on A4 and now you're
up to Pawns in a queen opponent game of
course you are you know you're winning
it's merely a matter of are you able to
win it so King to F3 Queen to F6 would
check King E2 and now King to H2 you
have to win the G5 pawn and start
advancing your pawns without uh allowing
black some sort of a weird drawing
maneuver so here Queen to G4 is actually
still a draw but a queen to H7 check was
played King to G2 now Queen E4 check
Ponte F3 uh we have Queen captures on A4
and just Queen captures and G5 so now
the two connected pass pawns will March
forward Queen A2 now comes uh Pawn to E4
we have Queen to B3 Queen to G3 and
queen to E6 we have Pawn to E5 the pawns
are now Unstoppable King E3 Ponte F4
with checking the four Queen to F2 with
checking E4 Queen F3 with checking the
four Queen G6 uh Queen to F5 and now
Queen to D1 again with check King E4
Queen F3 tracking the D4 King to G3
Queen to G6 check and queen to G4 uh you
have to figure out a safe way to get
your king of the board Queen D3 checking
a queen F3 a couple of repetitions here
then King H4 Queen H7 and now Queen to
H5 Queen E7 check you run away and now
Queen to F5 another queen G8 check Queen
G5 Queen the E6 check F5 now and this is
the way to advance otherwise you would
just have a repetition but here the
problem is if the pawn is captured then
Queen to F for check force is a queen
trade and after captress and captures
the pawn will be protected all the way
to the queening square it's a king to G6
King E7 King to G7 and the three squares
needed to promote your Pawn are defend
it of course completely winning so after
F5 we have Queen to A2 but now uh just
Queen tab for check King to D5 and King
to G5 the white king now marches up the
board Queen to B2 F6 Queen to G2 King to
H6 and he was in this position on move
86 that Richard resigned the game as
there is nothing more to be done here uh
the one way the game could continue is
of course a few more checks would be
given let's say queen G2 Queen G5 Queen
C2 checking G7 Queen C7 check F7 and
that's it and now after you try anything
uh even a nice Quinta D6
uh check will be enough for you to win
the game because you have to trade and
then of course the queen is completely
winning uh so yeah really a remarkable
game as expected uh you know Rapport
always plays uh wild openings and Wesley
does not back out from a challenge he
did grab that B7 point he said all right
show me the show me the the true uh
secrets of The Possession but uh there
weren't really any uh and Wesley just
won a very nice game and if you guys are
interested in the standings after first
three days of the super bet rapid
tournament uh Wesley uh Levon and young
shustoff do the art leading the
tournament with Five Points then with
four points Maxima Cheryl lagrav and uh
with three points that he had rapport
with two points uh uh a world rapid
Champion Magnus Carlsen uh with one
point Anish girian kilochenko and with
zero points so far Bolton Daniel Dak uh
so there we have it a very nice game I
hope you enjoyed it I hope to see more
incredible games being played today
three more rounds of Rapid will be
played uh I would like to thank David
Kimura AMD recent Enthusiast group
golfsoftware.com Paul hinemund and Gary
Shaw for a contribution to my channel
thank you a lot I really appreciate it
as usual you can check to all my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing the coverage of this
wonderful event and everything else
that's happening in the Chess World so
thank you all I will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day